في معمل الادويه الروسيه هذا والذي ينتج
منذ اكثر من 20 عاما نطاقا واسعا من
الادويه على راسها الانسولين تحدي
اتون الان منها زياده الانتاج في ظل
تقارير لجنه وزاره الصحه الروسيه عن وجود
قائمه بما يقرب من 100 دواء صنف في خانه
الادويه
في الصيدليات والمستشفيات
على خلفيه الاحداث الاخيره ازداد الطلب
على الادويه في روسيا واختفت بعض الادويه
من الصيدليات طررنا لزياده الانتاج من اجل
تامين السوق الروسيه بالادويه الهامه
لحياه الانسان لان الانسولين هو ماده هامه
لا يستطيع الانسان العيش من دونها
لم تكت هذه الشركه لتتعافى من تداعيات
كورونا وانقطاع الواردات من المواد الخام
حينها حتى بدات تواجه تداعيات العقوبات
التي فرضت على روسيا لتبدا البحث عن بدائل
للموردين للمواد والمعدات الطبيه
بعد فرض العقوبات ولكن خلال فتره قصيره
استطعنا تغيير المصدرين ووجدنا شركاء جددا
من الدول الصديقه والذين يستطيعون تصدر كل
ما يلزمنا من معدات ومواد اوليه استقلال
روسيا عن الادويه المستورده وزياده انتاج
الادويه المحليه هدفان وضعهما الرئيس
الروسي امام الصناعه الدوائيه في البلاد
مع التاكيد على ضروره زياده انتاج مواد
الخام المحليه لتحقيقها
الادويه ذات المجموعه الواسعه التطبيق لم
تختفي من السوق ولم ترتفع اسعارها لكن
الادويه الغاليه تمني وال
تي ترى الحياه في ظل
الامر نعم اختفت
وتراجعي نسبه الواردات من الادويه الى
روسيا الى نحو تسعه بالمئه تبقى التساؤلات
لدى المواطن الروسي حول مدى امكانيه شركات
الادويه المحليه تعويض هذا النقص